OR CONSULT YOUR PROGRAM GUIDE.
HERE'S CAROL ON THE U.S. SECRET
SERVICE.
... ...
AND YET OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF DECADES THE REPUTATION OF
THE CERVIX IS TO HAVE TAKEN A
BEATING.
I'M HOPING WE CAN GET DOWN TO
WHAT IS HAPPENED WITH THE
SERVICE AND WHAT CAN BE DONE
TO FIX IT.
SO NOW, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING KAROL AND EVAN.
>> KAROL GOOD TO BE WITH YOU,
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BOOK.
>> THINKING SO GLAD TO BEER
WITH EVAN.
'S DIRECT THINK OF THE BOOK IS
GREAT.
IT'S NOT ONLY GREAT READ BUT I
LEARNED A LOT.
HONESTLY I'M EMBARRASSED AS A
POLITICAL JUNKIE AND HISTORY
BUFF I FEEL LIKE I SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN MORE OF THIS THAN I
DID.
LET ME OFF THE HOOK, HOW MUCH
OF THIS DID YOU KNOW BEFORE
RESEARCHING THIS BOOK?
>> TO HAVE TO SAY I REALLY GOT
INTO THIS AND BEATS BY
ACCIDENT LOOKING AT SOMETHING
IN 2012 OF A TERRIBLE
SCANDAL.
I WAS REALLY SHOCKED ALMOST
EVERY TIME I DELVED INTO
ANOTHER PRESIDENCY AND THERE'S
SOMETHING NEW TO LEARN.
SOMETIMES THERE IS HEROIN
ASSUME, IT WAS SECURITY
DEBACLE.
>> AS YOU SAY THIS WAS AN
OUTGROWTH OF YOUR REPORTING
FOR THE POST ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL TRIP TO SOUTH
AMERICA IN 2012.
YOU'LL GET TO THAT.
I WANT TO ASK YOU GENERALLY
WHAT ABOUT THAT STORY STRUCK A
CORD?
OBVIOUSLY NOT EVERYTHING YOU
WRITE FOR THE PAPER HAS A BOOK
IN IT.
>> THE SECRET SERVICE STORY,
AND I WAS DRAWN INTO THIS IN
2012 AT LEAST IT WAS JUST THE
TWO SIDES OF THIS COIN.
THESE HEROIC PATRIOTS WE ALL
THINK ARE THE ELITE OF THE
ELITE.
COME DOWN SUPER FIT,
SUNGLASSES BUT AS I DID MORE
IMMORAL REPORTING ABOUT THEM I
WAS FINDING OUT THERE WAS A
LOT OF SERIOUSLY CONCERNING
STUFF.
THEY WERE WILLING TO TAKE A
BULLET FOR THE PRESIDENT.
BUT A LOT OF TIMES THEY ARE
DODGING A BULLET.
A LOT OF TIMES THEY'RE
COVERING UP, NOT THE SECRETS
OF THE PRESIDENT BUT THEIR OWN
MISHAP.
THEIR OWN MISCONDUCT.
>> OF THE GUY WAS LEFT
THINKING ABOUT HIS IMMEDIATE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE ARE IN
TODAY.
THEY TELL US EVERYTHING FOR IT
WE DO NOT HAVE TO WONDER
FORGET IN THE WHOLE STORY.
WE SEE BOTH THE VISIBLE PART
OF THE ICEBERG AND THE
SUBMERGED PART.
BUT IN TIMES PAST WHEN THERE
WERE NOT AS MANY PLACES TO GET
NEWS THEY ARE NOT AS MANY
ENTERPRISING REPORTERS, I
WONDER IF THAT'S PARTLY WHAT
SAVE THESE GUYS IN THE OLD
DAYS WAS THERE WAS JUST NO ONE
TO DO THE DIGGING INTO REPORT
ON THIS.
BECAUSE AS YOU SAY ALL THIS
STUFF WAS THERE.
YOU ARE REVEALING IT IN A WAY
THAT FOR US WE ARE GOING FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
BUT IT THINK IT'S BECAUSE NO
ONE WAS THERE TO TELL US
BEFORE, RIGHT?
>> I MEAN I THINK THERE WERE
SOME EXCELLENT REPORTERS BACK
IN THE DAY.
THERE'S ALSO A BIT OF A
GENTLEMEN'S AGREEMENT.
WE DID NOT COVER PRESIDENTS IN
THE MICROSCOPIC WAY THAT WE DO
NOW.
PRESIDENT KENNEDY, A LOT OF
REPORTERS KNEW THAT HE WAS
OFTEN TROTTING OFF ON BUSINESS
TRIPS REALLY PARTIALLY TO MEET
WOMEN.
THEY WERE NOT HIS WIFE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE KNEW WHAT WAS
HAPPENING BEHIND THAT
CURTAIN.
WHAT HE'S DOING AT THE SWIM
POOL AT THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN
JACKIE WAS AWAY.
BUT THE SECRET SERVICE AGENTS
ARE SOMETHING THAT ARE REALLY
DISCONCERTING.
WHILE THEY WERE NOT JUDGING
HIM MORALLY, THEY WERE JUDGING
HIM ON A SECURITY REASON.
THEY FELT LIKE HE WAS TAKING
HIS LIFE IN HIS OWN HANDS THE
WAY HE WAS INTERACTING WITH
PEOPLE HE DID NOT KNOW.
THE WOMEN THAT WERE UNSCREENED
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE DOOR
AND HOTEL ROOM THE AGENTS
COULD NOT SEE OR SCREEN.
TO MAXIMIZE BEING USHERED INTO
THE WHITE HOUSE BY FRIEND OF
THE PRESIDENT.
THAT HIS >> WILL COME TO
THOUGH, THE KENNEDY STORY IS
ONE OF MANY THAT I WANT TO BE
SURE WE GET INTO HERE.
LET ME STAY KINDA FAR BACK
FROM THIS AND ASKING
GENERALLY, AS YOU SAY
YOURSELF, YOU DID NOT GO INTO
THIS WITH A CONCLUSION ABOUT
THE SECRET SERVICE INTENDING
TO PROVE IT RIGHT OR YOURSELF
RIGHT WITH YOUR REPORTING.
BUT YOU DID GO INTO WITH A
POINT OF VIEW.
THOUGH SHAPED IN LARGE PART BY
THE 2012 EXPERIENCE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THOUGHT, EVAN, WHEN I DUG
IN, AGAIN I WAS ASKED TO HELP
BECAUSE I AM A DIGGER AND I
CONVINCE PEOPLE TO TALK TO ME
AND TELL ME THEIR TRUTHS.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS GOING TO BE
THE BIGGEST DEAL IN THE
WORLD.
THE MOST HUMILIATING SCANDAL
IN 100 YEARS.
BUT THOSE AGENTS I MET OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, SO MANY
DIFFERENT ONES I MET AS A
RESULT OF THAT REPORTING AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AND THEIR
FRIENDS AND OFFICERS, THEY HAD
A MUCH MORE HORRIFYING STORY
TO TELL THAT WAS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN BOYS GONE WILD
IN SOUTH AMERICA.
THAT WAS THEY THOUGHT A
PRESIDENT WAS GOING TO BE
KILLED ON THEIR WATCH.
>> IN SOME WAYS TELLING THE
STORY IS THE BEST WAY FOR THEM
TO CLEANSE THEMSELVES OR
CLEANSE THEIR GUILT AND MAYBE
CLEANSE THE SECRET SERVICE,
GETTING IT OUT THERE.
>> THEY REALLY DID NOT BELIEVE
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND THEY HAD
BEEN THROUGH SEVERAL
DIRECTORS.
THEY DID NOT BELIEVE THEIR
LEADERSHIP WAS LISTENING TO
THEM.
THEY BELIEVE THE ALPHA MAIL
DNA OF THIS AGENCY IS BOTH
AMAZINGLY CAPABLE OF DOING
HEROIC AND UNTHINKABLE THINGS,
SOME SACRIFICE WITH THEIR
LIVES BUT THE DNA ALSO DOESN'T
ADMIT WEAKNESS DOES NOT LIMIT
THE AGENCY IS STRUCK TO THIN.
A SECURITY SYSTEM IS SWISS
CHEESE RIGHT NOW.
>> MULTIPLE THINGS CAN BE TRUE
AT ONCE PER THEY CAN BE HEROES
AND A NEED OF SOME KIND OF
FIX.
YOU INTERVIEWED 180 PEOPLE
ROUGHLY FOR THIS BOOK.
IT SOUNDS LIKE MANY OF THEM
ARE HAPPY TO TALK TO AS LONG
AS YOU DID NOT IDENTIFY THEM.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE NEED
TO RELY ON ANONYMOUS SOURCES?
>> WELL UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS
INSTANCE IT WAS ABSENTLY
NECESSARY.
AGENTS ARE CURRENTLY ON-DUTY
AND OFFICERS WILL LOSE THEIR
JOB IF THEY SPEAK TO ME
WITHOUT PERMISSION.
AND SO I HAVE TO ADMIT AND SAY
WITH GREAT SADNESS THERE ARE
AGENTS WHO LOST THEIR JOBS FOR
TALKING TO ME.
ANONYMITY IS CRUCIAL FOR
THEM.
ON TOP OF THAT EVEN FORMER
AGENTS BECAUSE THE BACKLASH
FROM THE ALUMNI NETWORK.
WANT TO BURNISH THE ISSUE OF
AN IMPENETRABLE SECRET SERVICE
NOT WILLING TO WORK OUT FOR
THE CURRENT TEAM THAT IS
FIGHTING REALLY AGAINST THE
ODDS AND NEEDS HELP.
>> THEY WORKING REPORT
ESPECIALLY IN PAPER LIKE THE
POST WE ARE CALLED UPON TO
RELAY AN ANONYMOUS SOURCES TO
TELL US THINGS BE APTLY NEED
TO KNOW, YOU UNDERSTAND THE
TENSION THERE.
SO MY PEOPLE DISTRUST THE
MEDIA IF THEY SEE ANONYMOUS
SOURCES THAN THEY ARE GIVEN
PERMISSION NOT TO BELIEVE WHAT
THEY ARE READING.
YOU JUST HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT.
>> YES.
ALTHOUGH IN THIS BOOK AND IN
MY REPORTING, BUT ESPECIALLY
IN THIS BUCKET IS THE
BENEFICIARY OF COPIOUS
DOCUMENTS.
I CAN TELL YOU DOWN TO THE
NUMBER OF MOJITOS AND BEERS
THAT WERE SERVED BECAUSE
SOMEONE GAVE ME ALL THE
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION
DOCUMENTS.
SO MANY OF THESE AGENTS
ADMITTED TO ME THEIR
CALENDARS, THEIR SCHEDULES
THEIR CONTEMPORANEOUS TEXT AND
NOTES.
AND THEN THEY WERE BACKED UP
BY AGAIN INTERNAL DOCUMENTS.
>> SEE YOU ALLUDED TO THE
PREMISE OF THIS BOOK IS THE
STORIED ORGANIZATION IS
STRETCHED TOO THIN IT'S
DRONING AND OMISSIONS ARE
GREAT SECURITY RISK THERE'S
DISTRUST BETWEEN LEADERSHIP
AND RANK AND FILE.
I WOULD ALSO ADD AS WE SEE
REPEATEDLY LIKE SO MUCH OF
GOVERNMENT THERE OPERATING OUT
OF OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY THAT
DOES NOT KEEP UP WITH WHAT
THEY NEED IN THE MODERN
WORLD.
THERE'S A FRAT BOY CULTURE,
THIS ASPECT WHICH THE SERVICE
HAS BEEN DRAWN INTO POLITICAL
MATTERS ONTO HOPE THE SERVICE
IS POLITICAL BUT MAYBE IT'S
TOO MUCH TO ASK.
PEOPLE HATE WORKING THERE.
THAT'S THE PART I FELT MOST
REMARKABLE.
YOU SAY IT FINDS ITSELF IN A
STATE OF ON PRECEDENTED PERIL
SHOULD WE ALL FEAR FOR THE
COUNTRY UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES?
LEAVE ASIDE THE MYTH OF THE
SECRET SERVICE, AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER THEY ARE PROTECTING THE
MOST IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND IF THEY ARE IN THIS BAD OF
SHAPE SHOULDN'T WE ALL BE
CONCERNED?
>> YOU COULD NOT OF SAID IT
BETTER.
AND INDEED YOU VOICE EXACTLY
WHAT MY TOLD ME AGENT AFTER
AGENT OFFICER AFTER OFFICER
WHY DID THEY COME TO ME?
WHY DID THEY RISK THEIR
CAREERS WHY DID THEY PUT
SOMETHING ON THE LINE LIKE
THIS?
BECAUSE ALL OF THE WARNING
SIGNS THAT THEY KNOW FROM
HISTORY WERE FLARING BEFORE
KENNEDY WAS KILLED ARE FLARING
NOW.
OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY STRETCHED
TOO THIN STAFF.
PEOPLE BACK IN THE DAY I
INTERVIEWED LUCKILY SOME OF
KENNEDY'S AGENTS.
A FEW OF THEM DIED IN THE
COURSE OF ME WORKING ON THIS
PROJECT.
THEY SAID THEY KNEW THEY WERE
TREADING WATER.
THEY KNEW THEY WERE IN
TROUBLE.
THEY KNEW THEY COULD NOT KEEP
UP AND THAT'S WHAT AGENTS ARE
TELLING US NOW.
WE GOING TO WAIT FOR ANOTHER
DISASTER ARE WE GOING TO PAY
ATTENTION AND DO SOMETHING FOR
THEM.
>> THAT'S 50 YEARS AGO THAT'S
WHAT'S EXTERNAL IT'S BEEN
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE DESPITE
THE FACT IT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT A
NEW THOUGHT.
AS I'M READING THIS BOOK I'M
THINKING TO MYSELF WHAT DOES
SUCCESS LOOK LIKE FOR THE
SECRET SERVICE?
WHAT DOES THE JOB OF THESE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN?
DICK KAISER IS SPECIAL AGENT
FOR NIXON AND FORD SAID IN THE
BOOK QUOTE IS SAYING IN THE
BOOK FOR ME YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP
THEM SAFE.
THIS REDUCES TO THE OLD # YOU
HAD ONE JOB.
ONE JOB YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP THE
PRINCIPLES SAFE.
REALLY NOTHING ELSE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THAT.
>> IT IS SO VITAL.
THE REASON THE AGENCY MATTERS
TO ME AFTER LEARNING SO MUCH
ABOUT IT IS IT IS VITAL TO THE
DEMOCRACY.
IF THE PRESIDENT IS KILLED
EVERYONE WHO WAS LIVE AT THE
TIME, IF YOU THINK IS A GUT
PUNCH TO THE COUNTRY YOU
CANNOT IMAGINE HOW BAD IT WAS
FOR THE SECRET SERVICE.
BECAUSE IT WAS JOB ONE.
BUT THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THIS PROBLEM WITH THE MISSION
FOR IT ON TOP OF JOB ONE THERE
ARE 40 MORE PEOPLE THE SECRET
SERVICE PROTECTION.
THE AGENCY IS NOW PROTECTING
VICE PRESIDENT STEPCHILDREN
AND PRESIDENTS AND
GRANDCHILDREN AND ON TOP OF
CABINET SECRETARIES.
IT IS A HUGE MISSION PLUS THE
DRINK CYBERSECURITY AND
HACKING AND FINANCIAL, THEY
ARE PROTECTING SUPER BOWLS,
THEY ARE PROTECTING OLYMPICS.
EVERY SINGLE EVENT DOES NOT
INVOLVE THE PRESIDENT THEY ARE
STILL THERE.
AS ONE CABINET MEMBER TOLD ME
THIS AGENCY NEEDS A REFRESHER
ABOUT MISSION.
WE NEED TO MATCH UP ITS
MISSION AND THE TOOLS WITH THE
MONEY AND THE TOOLS WE GIVE
THEM.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE CANNOT
ACCOMPLISH WHAT THEY ARE
GIVEN.
>> AS YOU KICK THAT OFF, AND
HOW BROAD THE MISSION IS AND
HOW MANY COME TO INCORPORATE
IT'S EASY TO FORGET BACK WHEN
THE SECRET SERVICE CAME INTO
EXISTENCE REALLY STARTED AT A
COUNTERFEIT SQUAD.
AT THE TIME OF ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
IT EVOLVED AFTER MCKINLEY WAS
ASSASSINATED INTO THE ENTITY
IT IS TODAY.
INITIALLY THE PURPOSE OF THE
SECRET SERVICE WAS NOT TO
PROTECT IT WAS MUCH MORE
MUNDANE.
>> SO MUNDANE.
BASICALLY IT STARTS AFTER
LINCOLN WITH THE IDEA THERE'S
ALL THIS COUNTERFEIT MONEY AND
WE'VE GOT TO DEAL WITH TWO
THIRDS OF THE PAPER FLOATING
AROUND THE LAST YEAR SUBMIT
THE SECRET SERVICE WAS
AUTHORIZED BY PRESIDENT
LINCOLN THE DAY HE WAS SHOT
BUT NOT LAUNCHED AFTER HIS
ASSOCIATION FOR BATHROOM ARE
PRESENT TO BE ASSASSINATED
BEFORE THEY LEADER OF THE FREE
WORLD.
AND THE REASON WE ARE SO
AMERICAN, WE DON'T WANT A
ROYAL PALACE.
THE PUBLIC RECOILED AT THAT.
AND PRESIDENTS DID NOT THINK
THE TAXPAYERS/VOTING PUBLIC
WOULD COME TO THIS.
BUT AFTER MCKINLEY WAS KILLED
IN UPSTATE NEW YORK IN
BUFFALO, FINALLY PEOPLE
STARTED TO SAY DO YOU KNOW
WHAT?
THIS MANY PRESIDENTS KILLED
MAYBE WE SHOULD ACTUALLY
PROTECT THEM.
>> THEIR SALMON THINGS I
LEARNED ABOUT FROM YOUR BOOK
ABOUT THE SERVICE.
THE SERVICE HAS GROWN SO MUCH
OVER THE LAST SIX DECADES FROM
500 MILLION-DOLLAR BUDGET TO
7000 AGENTS IN A TWO-POINT TO
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUAL
BUDGET.
EXTRAORDINARY GROWTH.
I DID NOT KNOW THE FIRST AND
ONLY SECRET SERVICE OFFICERS
OR DIE WILL PROTECTING THE
PRESIDENT WAS AN ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT ON HARRY TRUMAN.
I ONLY KNOW THAT I KNEW THERE
WAS AN ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT
ON HARRY TRUMAN.
LESLIE GOES OUT A HISTORY
NOW'S THE ONE AND ONLY RIGHT?
AND YOU JUST MENTIONED THE
MISSION OF THE SERVICE AS AN
EXPANDED TO DO THINGS LIKE
PROTECT THE VICE PRESIDENT.
THE IDEA THAT WAS NOT PART OF
THE CHARGE FOR THE VERY
BEGINNING IS EXTRAORDINARY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE KAMALA HARRIS
IN THIS COUNTRY AT THIS MOMENT
WITHOUT A PROTECTED DETAIL?
>> KNOW I CANNOT.
I CANNOT.
IT TOOK THE ASSASSINATION OF
ROBERT KENNEDY, HE WAS
CAMPAIGNING AND LOOKING LIKE
HE WAS HEADED TO BECOME
PRESIDENT FOR LYNDON B JOHNSON
TO ANNOUNCE OVERNIGHT.
THAT WAS A REALLY CHILLING
MOMENT.
LITERALLY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT CALLED THE DIRECTOR THE
SECRET SERVICE AND SAID I WANT
DETAILS ON EVERY SINGLE
CANDIDATE RIGHT NOW.
SO CANDIDATES GOT PROTECTION
>> FAMILY MEMBERS AS YOU SAID
PRAY THE PROTECTION OF THE
SERVICES BEEN EXPANDED TO SO
MANY PEOPLE.
KAROL I DID NOT KNOW TO READ
THIS BOOK THAT ARTHUR BREMMER
WHO SHOT GEORGE WALLACE
ACTUALLY WANTED TO KILL
RICHARD NIXON FIRST.
AND WAS THWARTED.
>> THAT IS ACTUALLY GOOD STORY
FOR THE SECRET SERVICE.
HE RODE IN HIS JOURNAL THAT HE
WAS TRYING TO GET NIXON.
BUT IT WAS TOO TRICKY.
IT WAS TOO TRICKY TO GET.
HE WAS STRUGGLING BECAUSE THE
SECRET SERVICE MEN MADE IT TOO
HARD FOR HIM TO GET A CLOSE
ENOUGH SHOT.
SO GOOD FOR THEM.
KENNEDY'S ASSASSINATION REALLY
MADE THEM REBUILD THAT AGENCY
FROM THE GROUND UP WITH
RIGOROUS TRAINING, MAJORING
SECURITY.
IT'S BEEN SLEEPING FOR THE
PAST COUPLE DECADES.
>> IS NOT AWARE TO SOMETHING
YOU REFERRED TO IN THIS BOOK
THE EXCEPTIONAL CASE STUDY
PROJECT.
THIS IS WHERE AN ANALYSIS WAS
DONE OF 83 PEOPLE WHO ATTACKED
OR CAME CLOSE TO ATTACKING
PROMINENT FIGURES BETWEEN 1949
AND 1996.
THEY ARE NOT ALL PRESIDENTS.
BUT THAT THAT AWFUL LOT OF
INSTANCES OF ATTEMPTS, MANY
MORE THAN I KNEW THEN WE
PROBABLY REMEMBER.
THE POINT MADE AMONG OTHERS IN
THIS STUDY IS THAT MANY OF
THEM ARE ABOUT WEDDING FAITH.
THIS IS NOT POLITICAL
IDEOLOGIES RIGHT?
SOMETHING WITHOUT ABOUT THE
SECRET SERVICE IN THIS BOOK
FOR SURE IS THAT GOT A MUCH
TOUGHER JOB THAN EVEN WE KNOW
THERE ARE SO MANY MORE
ATTEMPTS THAT PEOPLE PROBABLY
READ ABOUT.
>> SO MANY.
EVEN BEFORE OBAMA, PRESIDENT
OBAMA WAS RUNNING FOR OFFICE
WHO KINDA SET THE RECORD FOR
THE NUMBER OF THREATS.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS PER MONTH
BUT IT REGISTERED A ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER.
SOMEBODY ON A STOOL HAD A FEW
TOO MANY TO DRINK CITIES IN
THE KILL THE PRESIDENT TO JUST
AN E-MAIL OR MORE FRIGHTENING
IN A WHITE SUPREMACY CHATTER
GROUP.
OR, MORE OFTEN AND WAS TRUE IN
THESE CASE STUDIES A PERSON
MENTAL STRUGGLES OR MAYBE IN A
CRISIS MENTAL HEALTH ESTATE
DECIDES THE WAY FOR THEM TO
SOLVE THEIR PROBLEM IS TO KILL
A PRESIDENT.
>> EVERYBODY HAS TO BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY THAT IS THE POINT.
YOU DO NOT KNOW SOMEONE WHO
SENDS AN E-MAIL IS A SERIOUS
THREAT OR NOT YOU GOT TO
INVESTIGATE EVERYTHING.
A NUMBER OF TIMES IN THIS BOOK
WE HEAR MORE AGENTS, MORE
AGENTS, MORE AGENTS.
WE NEED MORE AGES THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ANTIDOTES IF YOU CAN
RECOUNT THE SERVICE ITSELF OR
OTHERS GO TO CONGRESS OR THEY
SAY WE NEED MORE AGENTS.
THE PROBLEM IS WERE
UNDERSTAFFED.
IS THAT NECESSARILY AFTER ALL
OF YOUR REPORTING HAVE YOU
CONCLUDED THE ANSWER TO BETTER
SECRET SERVICE IS IT VOLUME,
MORE AGENTS MAKE FOR BETTER
SERVICE?
>> IN SOME WAYS YES.
BUT IN OTHER WAYS IS TOO
SIMPLISTIC.
AS YOU POINTED OUT, OMISSION
IS ENORMOUS IS GOTTEN LARGER
AND LARGER WE KEEP ADDING TO
THE PILE OF WHAT THE SECRET
SERVICE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR.
ON THE OTHER HAND YOU CANNOT,
NOT PROTECT KAMALA HARRIS YOU
CANNOT PROTECT THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND FAMILY.
YOU HAVE TO PROTECT HIS
PEOPLE.
THOSE DUTIES ARE
UNDERSTANDABLE.
BUT THE MISSION IT CREATES IS
ENORMOUS FOR THE OTHER THING
IS TECHNOLOGY.
THEY ARE SO LATE 1900S IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY HAVE FOR
TOOLS AT THEIR DISPOSAL.
SOME THINGS HAVE BEEN UPGRADED.
EVEN IN 2017 WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WAS JUST A FEW MONTHS INTO HIS
PRESIDENCY, THEY HAD ANOTHER
JUMPER INCIDENT WHERE THE
PERSON GOT OVER FIVE DIFFERENT
FENCES AND WAS ON THE GROUNDS
FOR 15 MINUTES WITHOUT BEING
INTERRUPTED, JIGGLED THE DOOR
ON THE EAST WING TO GET IN AND
WANDERED AROUND, AGAIN NO ONE
CATCHING HIM, WHY?
THE CAMERA, THE FENCE LINE THE
ALARMS, THE SENSORS, SO MANY
WERE FAILING.
THIS COULD NOT BE THE MOST
PROTECTED 18-ACRE COMPOUND IF
ALL THE SINS WERE ON THE FRITZ.
>> SO THERE'S THAT PROBLEM.
NOT SIMPLY ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
AGENTS.
YOU ALSO HAVE THIS PROBLEM
THAT SOMETIMES A PEOPLE BEEN
PROTECTED BY THE SECRET
SERVICE DO NOT WANT THEM
AROUND.
I KEPT THINKING TO MYSELF WAS
READING THIS BOOK THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE, PROTECT THESE
REFUSED TO BE PROTECTOR DO NOT
WANT TO BE PROTECTED.
USE THE CASE OF JOHN KENNEDY
THE MOST EXTREME CASE OF
SOMEBODY WHO'S TRYING TO CUT
AND RUN OR LEAVE IS DETAILS
YOU CAN GO OFF AND HAVE HIS
ADVENTURES.
THROUGH OTHER PEOPLE IN THIS
BOOK, PRESIDENT JOHNSON WE DO
NOT LIKE THE IMPOSITION.
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW THE
PURPOSE TO HAVE THEM AROUND IS
TO PROTECT THEM THEY WOULD
ASSUME NOT BE PROTECTED.
THAT'S ANOTHER POINT OF
TENSION.
>> ABSOLUTE SO GLAD YOU
BROUGHT IT UP.
PRESIDENT JOHNSON ASKED ME
CHUCKLE A LITTLE BIT, HE
ACTUALLY THREATENED AND ONE
TIME DID SHOOT OUT THE TIRE OF
A SECRET SURGES AGENT CAR ON A
FARM IN TEXAS.
HE KEPT THREATENING TO SHOOT
IT HE SAID USA TO GET BACK
AWAY FOR ME.
I'M HUNTING OUT HERE IN YOUR
MESSING IT UP.
>> YOUR GETTING IN THE WAY.
IN FACT THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT
JOHNSON KENNEDY 21 SEEN THE
AGENTS I SEPARATE FROM JOHN F.
KENNEDY'S ROMANTIC.
SEVEN FROM THAT.
THE OTHER REASON ONES THEY
DIDN'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WANTED A LOT OF SECRET
SERVICE GUARDS AROUND THEIR
PRESIDENT.
THEY WANTED TO FEEL THEY WERE
WAITED INTO A CROWD, NORMAL
JOE SAID HELLO TO HIS VOTERS
COQUETTE A BUNCH OF SECURITY
AROUND YOU GAVE THE IMPRESSION
YOU NEEDED TO BE PROTECTED
FROM YOUR OWN PUBLIC TRAIT
THEY DID NOT LIKE THAT AND I
THOUGHT TAXPAYERS TO BE TICKED
OFF ABOUT IT.
SO LYNDON B JOHNSON FOR
EXAMPLE COUNSELING TRYING TO
CUT THE SECRET SERVICE BUDGET
OR AT LEAST HIS DETAIL.
HE THOUGHT VOTERS DID NOT LIKE
IT.
MICK IS AND THERE'S SOMETHING
FUNDAMENTALLY THAT WE'D RATHER
HAVE A LIVE IMPRESSIVE TOO
MANY PEOPLE RATHER THAN A DEAD
PRESIDENT.
THE FACT IS THAT THE JOB OF
THE SECRET SERVICE TO PROTECT
THE PRESIDENT.
I FIND IT REMARKABLE THE
TAXPAYERS WILL NOT LIKE THIS
HOLDS ANY WATER BUT I'M MORE
SYMPATHETIC TO THE ARGUMENT
THAT WE WANT TO HAVE PRIVATE
LIVES.
WHETHER JOHN F. KENNEDY OR
MICHELLE OBAMA WE WANT THE
SECRET SERVICE TO LEAVE US TO
HAVE OUR PRIVATE LIFE NOT TO
IMPOSE IN THE WAY.
IT HAS THE WORD SECRET IN IT.
BUT OF COURSE THEY DO WORK FOR
US.
THAT TENSION THE IDEA MAY BE
STEEPED IN DEFERENCE AND
INDISCRETION.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THEY MAY
ALSO REVEAL THE SECRETS OF A
PRESIDENT OR FIRST FAMILY.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A CONCERN
ABOUT HER WORK, RIGHT?
>> THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
PRESIDENTS WHO HAVE HAD BETTER
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE SECRET
SERVICE THAN OTHERS.
THE BUSHES HAD AN INCREDIBLE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
CIRCUIT SECRET SERVICE DETAIL
PRETREATED THEM LIKE FAMILY
BARBARA BUSH BRINGING OUT
COFFEE BRING IN FOOD LEFT OVER
SUMMER PARTY.
EVEN TO THE POINT OF TELLING A
DETAIL LEADER FOR HER HUSBAND
THAT SHE WANTED HIM TO WEAR
HER HUSBAND'S HAT AND MITTENS
BECAUSE IT WAS COLD OUTSIDE.
VERY MOTHERLY ATTENTION AND
ACTUALLY WELCOMES, RIGHT?
WHEN THE CLINTONS ARRIVED THEY
WERE NOT SO SURE ABOUT THESE
AGENTS LOOKING OUT FOR THEM.
AND IN FACT IN THE FIRST FEW
WEEKS THE STORY LEAKED IN THE
PAPER ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON
DURING A LAMP AT HER HUSBAND
IN AN ARGUMENT.
SO AFTER THAT SHE WAS LIKE
OKAY IT TURNS OUT THESE AGENTS
LIKE THE BUSHES BETTER THAN
US, I DO NOT WANT THEM ON THE
SECOND FLOOR OF OUR HOUSE.
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO STAY
DOWNSTAIRS.
>> THE ISSUE OF THE SECRET
SERVICE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CLINTONS AND THE NOTION OF
DEFERENCE AND ALL OF THAT
COMES TO A HEAD DURING THE
INVESTIGATION WHEN THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THE SECRET
SERVICE WILL TELL WHAT THEY
SAW ON THE LUBINSKI MATTER.
AGAIN IT HAD NOT OCCURRED TO
ME THE SECRET SERVICE TO BE
PUT IN THE POSITION OF HAVING
TO PLAY THAT KIND OF ROLE.
MAYBE I NOTED THE TIME BUT
FORGOT IT.
BUT YOUR BOOK IN EXTRAORDINARY
DETAIL SUCH A COMPELLING STORY.
LET'S GET INTO SOME
PRESIDENCIES IF YOU DON'T MIND
FOR THIS TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THE STUFF YOU PRESENT TO US.
OBVIOUSLY THE KENNEDY
ASSASSINATION IS THE ONE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THINK ABOUT.
WE HAVE THE IMAGE OF THE
SECRET SERVICE AND WE THINK
ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED
ON THAT DAY AND AFTER.
AGAIN UNDER THE HEADING OF I
THINK I DO THIS BUT I FORGOT
IT OR MAYBE I JUST DIDN'T KNOW
IT.
IT DID NOT FULLY APPRECIATE
JACKIE KENNEDY BLAME THE
SECRET SERVICE.
BILL GREW THE DRIVER OF THE
LIMOUSINE AND AGENT IN THE
SERVICE YOU HAVE JACKIE IN
THIS BOOK SAYING BASICALLY IF
ONLY HE HAD DONE XYZ
DIFFERENTLY MAYBE THAT WOULD
NOT HAVE HAPPENED THAT IS
EXTRAORDINARY.
>> THIS WIDOW WITH THE BLOOD
STILL ON HER BEAUTIFUL PINK
SUIT WAS HOLDING ONTO HER
HUSBAND'S BRAIN PARTS AS THEY
ARRIVE.
>> LITERALLY CLUTCHING THEM A
PEACE OF HIS SKULL AND BRAIN.
>> HOLDING THEM AND HANDS THEM
TO A DOCTOR WHEN SHE GETS INTO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
YOU CANNOT PUT THIS PRESIDENT
BACK TOGETHER AGAIN.
THERE WERE SOME DOCTORS WHO
THOUGHT THERE WAS A CHANCE BUT
NOT MANY.
BUT SHE IS THIS AMAZING FIGURE
OF LIKE I AM GOING TO HOLD IT
TOGETHER FOR THE COUNTRY,
WHICH SHE DID FOR MANY, MANY
DAYS.
BUT IN HER PRIVATE MOMENTS SHE
SHARES THAT TAP ON THE BREAK
THAT BILL GREER THE AGENT OF
THE LIMO IN WHICH SHE IS
WRITING WITH HER HUSBAND, THE
TAP ON THE BREAK IN THE PLAZA
UPON HEARING THE FIRST SHOT
COME THROUGH THE RIGHT SIDE OF
EVERYBODY'S EARS IS LIKELY THE
REASON, FORGIVE ME, IS LIKELY
THE REASON ALL SMALL WAS ABLE
TO GET A THIRD FATAL SHOT THAT
WOULD DIRECTLY INTO THE JAW
AND EAR OF THE PRESIDENT.
AND DID RESULT IN A PART OF
HIS BRAIN SPLATTERING ON THE
BACKSEAT.
DIRECTLY CONTRASTED THAT WOULD
BE THE ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT
THE ATTEMPTED ASSASSINATION OF
RONALD REAGAN.
UNLIKE JACKIE KENNEDY NANCY
REAGAN'S AFTER THE WAY THE
AGENTS SAVED HIM.
SHE BELIEVED THE SYSTEM WORKED
EXACTLY AS IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO.
SO RATHER THAN RECRIMINATIONS
SHE FELT LIKE HAD IT NOT BEEN
FOR THE AGENTS HE MIGHT HAVE
SUCCUMBED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT HEROIC MOMENT SO MANY
LEVELS OF HEROISM AND SMART
QUICK REFLEXES ON THE SECRET
SERVICE THAT IS THE RESULT OF
THE REBUILDING OF THE GUT
PUNCH OF KENNEDY'S DEATH.
HE PUTS EVERYTHING HE HAS INTO
GETTING THE MONEY, GETTING THE
AGENTS GET IN THE TECHNOLOGY
ALL THAT UPGRADE HAPPENED AND
HIS CHOICES AND THE CHOICES OF
THE DIRECTOR THAT FOLLOW HIM
ARE COMPLETELY VINDICATED BY
THE SPLIT-SECOND DECISION OF
TIM MCCARTHY TO THROW HIS ARMS
UP AND TAKE INCOMING BULLETS
FROM JOHN HINCKLEY.
OR THE DECISION OF REAGAN'S
DETAIL LATER ON THAT SQUARE
OUTSIDE THE HILTON PUTS HIS
HAND ON THE SHOULDER AND
SHOVES THE PRESIDENT.
>> 70-YEAR-OLD MAN SHOVES THEM
INTO THE CAR, LANDS ON TOP OF
THEM.
REAGAN AT ONE POINT THANKS
THAT HIS RIB IS BROKEN BECAUSE
HE HAD PROBLEMS BREATHING
CADETS IN PART SMOTHERED IN
ASCENSION THE CAR BUT HE SAVED
HIS LIFE.
>> HE SAVED HIS LIFE AND THE
AGENT BEHIND THE, RATE
LITERALLY FOLDED UP I DON'T
HE'S GOING TO BREAK THE LEGS
OR NOT BUT LITERALLY FOLDED UP
THE LEGS OF THE AGENT BEHIND
HIM, GERRY WAS ON TOP OF THE
PRESIDENT SO THAT THEY COULD
SLAM THE LIMO DOOR SHUT AND
EVACUATE IMMEDIATELY.
IT WAS LIKE A VIETNAM EVENT
UNBELIEVABLE.
THEY WENT SO FAST THE AGENT
WAS DRIVING, SANG A MANTRA TO
HIMSELF OH MY GOD HOPE NOT RUN
OVER TO ME.
THERE IS ALSO JIM MCCARTHY.
>> CHAOS HOW MUCH WORSE IT
COULD HAVE BEEN EVERYBODY MADE
GREAT DECISIONS.
THE FACT THAT HINCKLEY WAS
ABLE TO BE 11 SEATS FROM THE
PRESIDENT WAS A FAIRLY BREAD
THAT'S WHAT THEY DID WRONG.
BUT WHAT THEY DID RIGHT SO
OVERSHADOWED.
>> WENT TO >> TO REAGAN IN A
SECOND RING THE REAGAN
CONTRAST BUT I WANT TO GO BACK
TO NIXON FOR THE INTERESTING
TAKE WITH YOUR WRITING ABOUT
NIXON WAS THE DEGREE TO THAT
NIXON POLITICIZE OR ATTEMPTED
TO POLITICIZE THE SERVICE.
BY MY COUNT THE BIG GRIEVANCE
ATTEMPTS HE WON INTO USED TO
ATTRACTED KENNEDY BECAUSE HE
FEARED KENNEDY AS A POLITICAL
THREAT EITHER IN THE 72
ELECTION OR HE WANTED TO
DISABLE POTENTIALLY FOR 76.
NIXON IS RELYING ON THE
SERVICE TO TAKE ON A NUMBER OF
EXPENSES THAT WERE NOT
LEGITIMATELY RENOVATION
EXPENSES THAT NIXON'S PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
AND THEN ALSO NIXON'S ATTEMPT
TO USE SECRET SERVICE MEMBERS
TO REMOVE PROTESTERS, TO
BASICALLY DISABLE THE ABILITY
OF AMERICANS TO PROTEST
PEACEFULLY IF NOT LOUDLY
AGAINST THEIR GOVERNMENT.
IT REMINDED ME OF WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE TRUMP
YEARS.
>> IT REMINDED ME OF THE SAME.
SO MANY EERIE PARALLELS WITH
NIXON AND TRUMP JUST READ THE
SECRET SERVICE.
THIS IDEA FOR HANDLING ANTIWAR
PROTESTER AND ANTI- NIXON
PROTESTERS BY SECOND THE
SECRET SERVICE ON THEM AND
USING THEM AS A TOOL LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S THESE ARE MY
GOONS DEPLOYED IN THE SAME
LOOKING AS THE LAW AND ORDER
PRESENT THE TOUGH GUY NIXON
WANTED TO DO THE SAME.
WHEN HE WAS RUNNING FOR
REELECTION HE WANTED TO HAVE
THESE IMAGES OF THESE VICIOUS
SAVAGE PROTESTERS FIGHTING
WITH THE SECRET SERVICE SO
THOSE COULD BE THE IMAGES IN
THE NEWS PAGES.
AND THAT COULD SHOW THE VOTERS
WHO WAS GOING TO KEEP THEM
SAFE, PRESIDENT NIXON.
>> Host: >> TO REAGAN.
SOME OF IT MAY BE NEW PICTURE
BOOK REMINDED ME, PRESIDENT
REAGAN WHEN HE WAS SHOT LOST
NEARLY HALF THE BLOOD IN HIS
BODY.
I REMEMBER BEING IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL WHEN PRESIDENT REAGAN
WAS SHOT.
HEARING ABOUT IT KNOWING
ENOUGH IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME NEVER
THINKING HE ALMOST DIED HE
LOST NEARLY HALF THE BLOOD IN
HIS BODY.
>> IT IS A STUNNING, STUNNING
THING.
HATS OFF TO GEORGE WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY'S DOCTORS BROUGHT
THEM BACK TOGETHER THEY DEALT
A LOT OF CHALLENGES.
MAYBE NOT AWARE OF IT AT THE
TIME THE SECRET SERVICE WERE
SERIOUSLY KEEPING THAT UNDER
WRAPS.
HOW CLOSE HE CAME AT SOMETHING
WE LEARNED LATER.
>> THE SURGEONS DUG OUT A
DEVASTATED BULLET OUT OF THE
SIDE OF HIS LONG WHICH WAS
HIDDEN BEHIND A RIB IT WAS
REALLY HARD FOR THEM TO FIND.
SEE WHAT YOU MENTIONED AT
THINGS CHANGE OF THESE
DIFFERENT INSTANCES.
QUOTE A COUPLE TIMES IN THE
BOOK EVERY TIME THE SERVICES
TESTED TO GETS BETTER.
THE ASSUMPTION IS THEY GO
THROUGH JFK.
AFTER JFK THE GOING TO CHECK
THE SECURITY OF BUILDINGS ON
THE MOTORCADE ROUTE TO PUT
THAT SNIPER FIRE.
IS GOING TO BE NO MORE OPEN
TOP CONVERTIBLES.
AFTER THE WALLET AGENDA GOING
TO CHANGE POLICIES BUT AFTER
THE REAGAN ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT GOING TO ADD
MAGNETOMETERS WERE GOING TO
HAVE COVERED ARRIVALS.
ALL THIS SEEMS SMART AND
NORMAL.
BUT TO A CIVILIAN I'M THINKING
OF COURSE.
BUT THEN I'M THINKING BACK TO
THE CAPITOL INSURRECTION WERE
AFTER THE CAPITOL INSURRECTION
A COUPLE MONTHS AGO NANCY
PELOSI AND THE SECURITY DETAIL
IN THE HOUSE THE CAPITOL
POLICE ARE GOING TO ADD METAL
DETECTORS, RIGHT?
IN SUCH A POINT OF CONTROVERSY.
THE ANSWER TO EVERY QUESTION
IS >> TO LIBERTY AS OPPOSED TO
THE LEADERS OF OUR COUNTRY MAY
HAVE TO PROTECT THEM.
AS MUCH AS WE SEE THE SECURITY
PROTOCOLS EVOLVE OVER TIME WE
KNOW THIS BETTER THAN ANYONE.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS SECURITY
MIXED WITH POLITICS.
NANCY PELOSI HAS NEVER REALLY
WANTED AND HAS PRETTY MUCH
RESISTED A FENCE AROUND THE
CAPITOL, WHY?
IT LOOKS TERRIBLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT LIKE
THE NEW FENCE DESIGN THEY WERE
ENVISIONING TO TRY TO PREVENT
THESE JUMPER INCIDENTS THAT
WERE SO HUMILIATING.
HE SAID IT LOOKS LIKE A PRISON.
KENNEDY DID NOT WANT DETAIL
AGENTS ON THE BACK OF HIS CAR
WHEN THEY WERE RIDING IN
MOTORCADE'S.
CLINT HILL WILL TELL YOU THEY
BEGGED AND BEGGED TO BE ON THE
BACK OF THAT CAR.
>> HAD THEY BEEN AT MIGHT HAVE
VENTED OSWALT OF HAVING A GOOD
SHOT AT THE PRESIDENT, RIGHT?
>> ONE 100%.
A FIGHTING CHANCE TO PREVENT
HIS DEATH.
LESSIE SAID TO ME AND OTHERS
HE WOULD'VE TAKEN THAT
BULLET.
HE WOULD'VE GOTTEN IN BETWEEN
IT AND THE PRESIDENT.
WE DO NOT ONE THAT THAT IS
WHAT THEY SIGNED UP FOR.
ALL OF THESE SECURITY ISSUES
WHEN YOU MIX THEM WITH
POLITICS WITH THEIR POLITICAL
IMPRESSION, YOU DO NOT GET A
PURE SECURITY ANSWER.
>> IT'S ALWAYS A TENSION
BETWEEN FREEDOM AND SECURITY.
WITH ALWAYS WEATHERS WITH THE
SECRET SERVICE OF THE CAPITOL
FENCING, RIGHT YOU WANT TO
PROTECT EVERYONE YOU ALSO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO BE FREE.
I HAD THIS POINT IN THE BOOK
AWARE DID EVERYTHING GO
WRONG?
THE PROBLEMS YOU IDENTIFY HAD
BEEN A PLAGUE ON THE SECRET
SERVICE FOR YEARS.
AGAIN WE MAY NOT HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT THEM IN THE WORLD.
FROM AGENTS ANNETTE I CANNOT
HELP BUT NOTE YOUR CHAPTER ON
THE OBAMA YEARS IS TITLED THE
WHEELS COME OFFERED AS IF
SOMEHOW THE WHEELS HAD BEEN ON
PREVIOUSLY.
BUT IT WAS REALLY IN THE OBAMA
YEARS WE REALLY SEE THE
PROBLEMS UP CLOSE, RIGHT?
THEY SEEM IF ANYTHING TO GET
WORSE.
>> THEY ABSOLUTELY GOT WORSE.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS GOING ON
AT THE SAME TIME.
ONE IS THAT AFTER CLINTON'S
PRESIDENCY THERE IS AN EFFORT
ESPECIALLY BY PRESIDENT
CLINTON TO KEEP AGENTS AWAY
FROM HIM.
AS THEY GET FURTHER AND
FURTHER AWAY THEIR ABILITY TO
SECURE HIM REDUCES.
SEGMENT OF THE TV PRESIDENT
REDO NOT WHAT THE AGENTS IN
THE SHOT, KEEP THEM A LITTLE
BIT FURTHER AWAY.
WE WANT STRONG INDEPENDENT
PRESIDENT NO ONE PROTECTS HIM
NO ONE IS TO BE THERE.
THAT STARTS A DOWNWARD CYCLE
IN TERMS OF THE RIGOR OF THEIR
SECURITY.
THERE IS ALSO THE MISCONDUCT
IS ALLOWED BECAUSE ARROGANCE,
SECRECY LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
IN THE CULTURE OF THE SECRET
SERVICE.
THEY CAN KEEP CLASSIFIED
PROGRAMS AND IMPORTANT TO
PROTECT THE PRESIDENT'S SECRET
THEY SEEM TO BELIEVE THEY CAN
ALSO KEEP THEIR WEAKNESSES AND
SOME OF THEIR HUMILIATING
EPISODES A SECRET.
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS COME TO A
HORRIBLE HEAD DURING PRESENT
OBAMA'S TWO ADMINISTRATIONS
PURCHASED EPISODE AFTER
EPISODE.
BUT BOTH KINDS SECURITY GAPS
AND UNBELIEVABLE BAD BOY.
>> I WAS CHRONICLING AS I'M
READING AND WRITING DOWN
EVERYTHING BAD THAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE OBAMA YEARS.
A CERTAIN POINT I JUST HAVE TO
STOP.
BECAUSE THE VOLUME OF IT WAS
TOO MUCH GRID HAVE THE
EXTRAORDINARY RACIST CULTURE
OF THE SERVICE COME OUT
HORRIBLE E-MAILS AND HORRIBLE
RACIST JOKES THAT ARE BEING
MADE.
MEMBER PRESIDENT OBAMA IS A
SPECIAL CASE AND THAT HE IS
THE FIRST BLACK PRESIDENT
ULTIMATELY, HE
RECEIVED SECRET SERVICE
PROTECTION THE EARLIEST ANY
CANDIDATE HAS RECEIVED
SECURITY IN THE HISTORY OF THE
PROTECTIVE DETAIL, RIGHT?
YOU HAVE THE SOUTH AMERICAN
TRIP THAT WAS THE BASIS FOR
YOUR STORY BECAUSE YOU OWN
THAT >>.
YOU GO INTO EXCRUCIATING
DETAIL IN THE BOOK.
AND SO YOU KNOW EVERY SINGLE
THING TWIST AND TURN THAT
HAPPENS PRETTY HAVE THE FENCE
JUMPER THE GETS INTO THE WHITE
HOUSE IN 2014 I THINK HIS NAME
IS ORTEGA IS THAT RIGHT?
THIS IS A COMEDY AFFAIRS
EXCEPT IS NOT EVEN A LITTLE
BIT FUNNY.
HOW YOU REFER EARLIER TO THE
TRUMP INSTANCE HAD THIS GUY
MANAGED TO ESCAPE, HAVE THE
AGENTS WHO DRIVE DRUNK INTO
THE SECURITY BARRIER.
THEN FOR GOOD MEASURE YOU HAVE
THAT LEAKING OF JASON CHAPIN'S
FAILED SECRET SERVICE
APPLICATION.
THIS IS ALL WITHIN A PERIOD OF
A FEW YEARS AND IT IS
EXTRAORDINARY TO ME THAT
NOTHING SEEMS TO IMPROVE
DURING THAT PERIOD THE SHOCKER
IS EVERYONE IN THE OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE THREW UP THEIR HANDS
AFTER THE JUMPER AND AFTER
ANOTHER INCIDENT THAT FOLLOWED
MINUTES AFTER ALMOST WHICH IS
AN ELEVATOR GUARD WHO WAS
ALLOWED TO GET CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT WITH A WEAPON.
STRICTLY ACTION HAD A WEIRD
HISTORY DIDN'T HE?
HE HAD A HISTORY THAT WOULD'VE
SUGGESTED YOU DO NOT WANT THIS
PRESIDENT BY CONVENTIONAL
STANDARDS NEAR THE PRESIDENT.
>> ANYBODY WHO IS NOT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAN SHOULD NOT
HAVE A WEAPON AND BE NEAR THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS PERSON HAD BEEN CHARGED
NOT CONVICTED BUT CHARGED WITH
SOME CRIMES THAT INVOLVED A
GUN.
>> SHOULD BEEN A RED FLAG
BIRDS TO MAKE A RED FLAG
EVERYBODY SHOULD BEEN SCREENED
BOTTOM LINE.
AFTER THESE TWO THINGS HAPPEN
THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE IS LIKE
OKAY WE ARE DONE.
THE PAST HAD PRESSURE FOR THE
DIRECTOR'S RESIGNATION
THINKING A WILL MAKE THINGS
ALL THE BETTER.
BUT WHEN THEY BRING BACK
FATHER JOE, JOE CLANCY WHO
USED TO BE THE HEAD OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S DETAIL, HE
FEELS REALLY COMFORTABLE WITH
SOME OF GREAT RECTITUDE, A
GREAT COACH.
WHEN THEY BRING HIM BACK AND
THEY ARE ALL TAKING A BIG SIGH
OF RELIEF.
THINGS ARE GOING TO GET BETTER.
BUT NO, THINGS DO NOT GET
BETTER.
AND NOTHING CHANGES THE STATUS
QUO.
ON THESE TWO PEOPLE ONE THE
HIGHEST RANKING MEMBER OF THE
PRESIDENT'S DETAIL IN CHARGE
OF ALL SECURITY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE LEAVES THE RETIREMENT
PARTY DRUNK AS A SKUNK AND
COMES BACK ONTO THE WHITE
HOUSE COMPOUND WITH ANOTHER
INEBRIATED PERSON.
THEY DRIVE THEIR GOVERNMENT
CAR FLICKERED GET ANOTHER CAR
OVER SIS POSITION PACKAGE
INVESTIGATION FOR THIS IS NOT
THE BEHAVIOR OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON THEIR GAME AT ALL TIMES.
>> OR FUNCTIONAL ENTITY.
WE DO NOT HEAR THE STORIES AND
THINK IT'S OKAY WE DID NOT
EVEN MENTION THE BULLET THAT
PIERCED THE RESIDENCE OF THE
WHITE HOUSE AND MRS. OBAMA
GOES BANANAS OVER THIS.
>> YOU ARE THE FIRST LADY FIND
OUT FROM THE WHITE HOUSE USHER
FIVE DAYS AFTER THE FACT THAT
THE HOUSE TO THAT YOUR
CHILDREN MORE IN WAS SHOT AT
WHILE YOU WERE AWAY, I DOES
NOT A GOOD WAY TO LEARN THE
INFORMATION IF YOU ARE A MOM,
MUCH LESS THE FIRST LADY.
>> EXTRAORDINARY.
WE GET INTO THE TRUMP YEARS
WHAT ARE THE BIG TAKEAWAYS
FROM JUMP IN THE SECRET
SERVICE?
>> FOR SOME OF THE COST FOR
THIS LOT OF COSTS IT SERVED
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THANKS TO THE REPORTING TO
COGS IN THE POST ROAD WERE
FINDING OUT IS WHAT WE KNEW
THE WHITE STANDARDS THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
NONE TRUMP YEARS BY THE SERVER
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN MEN
PROTECTED IN A NORMAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> WAS BREAKING THE BANK FOR
THEIR 42 PEOPLE INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT.
AT ONE POINT THE HEADS THE
DEPARTMENT OF SECURITY JOHN
KELLY ENDED UP BEING THE CHIEF
OF STAFF TRIES TO GET SOME
PEOPLE TO GIVE UP THEIR DETAIL
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT UNDER ANY
KIND OF SECURITY THREAT.
UST MEN KNEW.
WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
PROTECT THE PRESIDENT CAN WE
HAVE YOUR DETAIL?
STEVE MNUCHIN GOES BANANA HE
WAS A KEEP HIS DETAIL.
OTHERS GIVE THEM UP.
KELLYANNE, GIVE UP HER DEACON
TELL SHE WASN'T THRILLED ABOUT
BUT SHE GAVE IT UP BECAUSE IT
WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
>> IT SOME POINT YOU GOT TO
MAKE CHOICES PRETTY MENTION
THE PRESIDENT WANTING TO
STATIC CHANGES THE FENTANYL
THAT.
HE WANTED TO REMOVE THOSE
MOVABLE POSTS TO BACK THE
UNDERGROUND GATES THAT RISE
AND FALL.
>> YOU DO NOT THE FACT THAT WE
RUN OVER THEM THEY MADE IT
UNPLEASANT NOISE OR IT WAS A
LITTLE JARRING.
TO ME, THE THING I SUPPOSE I
SHOULD NOT BE SURPRISED ABOUT
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT WAS SO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LOOK OF
THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM FOR FOUR
YEARS WAS THE CONCERN THEY
WERE OVERWEIGHT PEOPLE ON THE
SECURITY DETAIL.
I WANT THESE FAT GUYS OFF MY
DETAIL IS AN ACTUAL QUOTE FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE SAID IT BECAUSE HE WAS
CONCERNED JOB IN THE SHAPE TO
PROTECT EMPEROR THERE'S A
PHYSICAL ASPECT OF IT.
YOU CANNOT HELP BUT THINK THE
PRESIDENT WAS A CASTING
DIRECTOR FOR HIS
ADMINISTRATION AND CHIEF IS
THINKING, PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
LOOK THE IMAGE I WANT THEM TO
LOOK.
BACK TO IT SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE CONVERSATION WITH THE
HOLLYWOOD IMAGE OF THE SERVICE
THEY WERE BANISHED FROM HIS
DETAIL.
VACUUM DRAW SUCH A BEAUTIFUL
LINE THAT WORRIES ABOUT
SERVICE BUT PART OF THE REASON
I WROTE THE BOOK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TAKES OVER AT
A TIME WHEN THE SERVICES
RECOVERING AND TRYING TO
REBUILD.
TRYING TO REBUILD.
IT GONE THROUGH A HORRIFIC
EIGHT YEARS EPISODE AFTER
EPISODE AFTER EPISODE.
BUT WHAT DOES DONALD TRUMP
CARE ABOUT?
USING THEM ASA TOOL OPTICS
OVER REALITY BRIDGES NOT CARE
ABOUT GOVERNING.
HE'S NOT PAID ANY ATTENTION TO
THE SHORTCHANGED NATURE.
INSTEAD HIS TRAVEL BLEEDS THEM
DRY.
$30MILLION IS NECESSARY IN THE
SPRING OF 2017 PRAISE ONLY
BEEN PRESIDENT FOR A FEW WEEKS.
THE SECRET SERVICE MAKES AN
EMERGENCY REQUEST THEY KNOW
THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO KEEP
UP EVEN THE BASIC BARE MINIMUM.
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT'S GOING
TO MAR-A-LAGO EVERY OTHER WEEK
INTO GOLF AND TRAVEL PARADE
THAT IS VERY UNUSUAL.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL FOR PRESIDENT
TO TRAVEL IT'S UNUSUAL FOR
THEM HAVE LEISURE TRAVEL THAT
PUTS MONEY AND POCKET OF THEIR
OWN COMPANY, TAXPAYER MONEY.
>> IS QUITE A BIT OF CONCERN
ABOUT OBAMA'S WITH SECURITIES
THE VERY FEW MONTHS THE TRUMP
YEARS IT SEEMED LIKE TRUMP IS
GOING TO FAR EXCEED THE
WORSE.
AS YOU POINT OUT SOME OF THAT
MONEY HAD TO ACTUALLY GO TO
TRUMP OWN BUSINESSES.
OUR MIND TO PROTECT THE
PRESENT HARDWOOD NORMALLY
EXPECT TO HAVE TO PAY.
ULTIMATELY END UP IN THE
POCKETS OF TRUMP ASSOCIATES.
YES.
AFTER GREAT LINE, DONALD TRUMP
ARRIVE, THE SERVICE NEEDS HELP.
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
FAT OR NOT ALTHOUGH MANY
AGENTS OF THE THINK THE
PRESIDENT MISUNDERSTOOD WHO HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
THOSE WERE OTHER PEOPLE BUT
WHATEVER.
THE OPTICS ARE MORE IMPORTANT
AND THE SERVICE LEADERSHIP
GETS TO TAKE A PASS AND NOT
LOOK HARDER AT THEIR BIGGER
PROBLEMS DEEPER WITHIN.
>> I THINK THE OBAMA AND TRUMP
YEARS ARE SEPARATE BUT
RELATED.
THAT FACT AT THE FIRST BLACK
PRESIDENT.
THE NATURE OF THE THREATS TO
THE FIRST BLACK PRESIDENT AND
HIS FAMILY ON THE ONE HAND.
ON THE OTHER HAND THE
CHALLENGE OF THE KINDS OF
RALLIES AND THE KINDS OF RALLY
GOERS IN THE TRUMP YEARS.
TO MEET THOSE PRESENT REAL
SERIOUS CHALLENGES.
EVEN FOR A SECRET SERVICE AT
ITS BEST LET ALONE A SECRET
SERVICE THAT IS SHORTSTAFFED
AND UNDER BUDGET.
>> SO TRUE.
DIRECTOR CLANCY WHO WAS STILL
DIRECTOR, FORGIVE ME WHILE
DONALD TRUMP WAS RUNNING
AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON, DAVID
INTERVIEW IN WHICH HE SAID IT
WAS THE MOST CHAOTIC CAMPAIGN
HE'D EVER SEEN IN HIS LIFE.
AND HE WAS MORE CAREFUL IN HIS
LANGUAGE THAN OTHERS.
BUT AGENTS TOLD ME THEY'D DONE
TO HIM THE CHAOS CAN AND HE
WAS INCITING VIOLENCE AT HIS
OWN RALLIES.
PROTESTERS WHO ARE ANTI- TRUMP
ARRIVED HE WOULD ENCOURAGE HIS
RALLY GOERS TO PHYSICALLY
ATTACK THEM.
SAYING HE WOULD PAY THEIR
LEGAL BILLS.
WE REMEMBER THAT RIGHT?
>> IF YOU GET IN TROUBLE I
WILL PAY YOUR BILLS.
THERE IS A HORRIBLE SCENE
WHERE A WOMAN FROM THE
UNIVERSITY IN LOUISVILLE IS AT
A KENTUCKY CONVENTION CENTER
WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS
SPEAKING.
SHE HAS COME BASICALLY TO
PURCHASE IS ANTI- MUSLIM
RHETORIC.
SHE IS PUSHED AROUND LIKE A
RAGDOLL.
SHE IS BLACK, SHE IS WEARING A
BACKPACK.
SHE HAS A FOAM AND SHE IS
FILMING WHAT IS HAPPENING.
TO HER.
WATCHING IT FROM UP ABOVE IS
HORRIFYING.
AS MEN SPIT ON HER, CALL HER
NAMES, AND ALMOST PUSH HER TO
THE GROUND.
BUT THEY DID SO AT DONALD
TRUMP SURGEON.
>> ANOTHER WAY WHEN TO ASK YOU
THIS QUESTION IS THE CRITICAL
ENVIRONMENT HAD TO PRESENT
MORE OF A THREAT THE TOXICITY
OF THE PERVASIVENESS OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE ONCE DISMISSED AS
RIDICULOUS AND NOT EVEN WORTH
PAYING ATTENTION TO.
THE KID WHO SHOT UP THE WHITE
HOUSE DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS INSPIRED BY
ALEX JONES MOVIE.
WHAT MUST IT BE LIKE TODAY FOR
THE SERVICE HAVING TO DEAL
WITH EVERYTHING ELSE NOW
SUDDENLY HAVING TO DEAL THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORY FUELED
ATTACKS OR CONSPIRACY THEORY
INSPIRED RALLIES THAT
THEMSELVES CREATE MORE
PROBLEMS FROM A PROTECTIVE
STANDPOINT.
>> WELL, SUCH A WISE SET OF
WORRIES.
LOOKS WHAT HAPPENED JANUARY
6.
NOBODY IMAGINED IT.
BUT NOBODY REALLY COULD HAVE
HANDLED IT OTHER THAN SEVERAL
WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD WE
CANNOT PRETEND THE SLIGHTLY
LARGER CAPITOL POLICE FORCE
COULD HANDLE THAT.
JUST A STUNNING DISPLAY OF THE
STATE IN WHICH OUR COUNTRY IS
NEARLY CIVIL WAR PROPORTIONS.
>> AS YOU POINT OUT THERE A
NUMBER SECRET SERVICE AGENTS
WHO POST INSURRECTIONS WE
LEARNED SYMPATHIZED OR AT
LEAST EMPATHIZED WITH THE
RIOTERS WHICH GIVES BACK TO
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER THE
SECRET SERVICE CAN PROPERLY BE
APOLITICAL.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE POLITICAL
POINTS OF VIEW.
THE PREMISES GOING TO CHOOSE
OUR NOT CHOOSE TO UNLOCK THAT
PART OF IT.
THEY THEMSELVES MAY HAVE
POLITICAL POINTS OF VIEW.
THAT COMPLICATE MATTERS
FURTHER.
>> YOU KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IN AMERICA IS ALMOST
ALWAYS GOING TO TREND
CONSERVATIVE.
BUT I WAS GOB >> TO HAVE AGENT
SEND ME THE SCREENSHOTS OF
THEIR COLLEAGUES WHO WERE ON
THE PRESIDENTIAL DETAIL
CHEERING FOR THE PATRIOTS WHO
HAD STORMED THE CAPITOL TO
STOP THE STOLEN ELECTION.
IF YOU HAVE THE MOST ELITE
AGENCY PROTECTION IN THE WORLD
ALLEGEDLY, AND SOME MEMBERS
ARE STOKING THE BELIEF THAT
BIDEN IS NOT A LEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT, HOW SAFE IS THE
DEMOCRACY HOW SAFE IS PRESENT
BIDEN?
BECKY DID NOT WRITE ABOUT
BIDEN REMISSION THIS BOOK.
THERE IS SOME MENTION OF THE
NEW PRESIDENT.
YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT IT
HAS BEEN LIKE SO IF THERE'S A
PAPERBACK VERSION OF THIS
BOOK, WHICH THERE WILL BE
THEORETICALLY THE NEW MATERIAL
WILL BE ABOUT THE FIRST PERIOD
OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WHETHER HE WAS ABLE TO RESET
EVERYTHING OR IF IT WAS THE
SAME?
WHAT IS YOUR SENSE?
>> A LOT OF SENIOR FORMER
AGENTS THAT WERE CLOSE OR
TRYING TO SPREAD THE WORD,
THROUGH MY BOOK.
POINTING TO IT BUT ALSO THEIR
OWN EXPERIENCE JUST TO SAY
IT'S TIME TO FIX IS NOT WAIT
FOR A DISASTER GOING TO PAY
ATTENTION NOW OR WAIT UNTIL
SOMETHING HORRIBLE HAPPENS?
WE TOOK THREE ASSASSINATIONS
BEFORE THEY STEPPED UP AND
STEPPED IN.
>> I REALLY HOPE SO.
SO IT I LOVE THIS BOOK IS SO
GREAT TO TALK TO.
I FEEL LIKE THEY REALLY HAVE
LEARNED AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT NOT
ONLY READING THE BOOK BUT
SPEND THIS TIME WITH YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
TIME FOR ME.
>> I REALLY LOVE TALK ABOUT IT
WITH YOU, THANK YOU.
>> AND CUTE CAROLYN EVAN THAT
WAS REALLY ENLIGHTENING.
I'M IMAGINING A LOT OF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A COPY OF
THIS BOOK, ZERO FAILED THE
RISE AND FALL OF THE SECRET
SERVICE.
WE DO HAVE SIGNED BOOK PLAY
DID COPIES AVAILABLE AT OR LBJ
STORE.
YOU CAN ACCESS L